Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
(Musica)
Five, four, three, two, one.
(Applausi)
Buongiorno.
Buongiorno. Salve!
È veramente una coincidenza
trovarmi qui
perché in realtà
sono stato contattato da Andrea
solo pochi giorni fa, mi ha detto:
"Se sei a Bologna non puoi fare
a meno di passare al Tedx."
Mi ha fatto un'offerta
che non potevo rifiutare
come dice il famoso film
con un altro siciliano.
Bene. Quando mi ha contattato
mi ha detto che il tema...
uno dei temi di questoTedX era
"Meraviglia nell'oscurità".
Quindi si parla di oscurità
e meraviglia nella stessa frase
e mi ha colpito molto,
credo che da astronauta
ci sono molti punti
di collegamento in questo.
Lo spazio è un luogo
dove si fa innovazione.
Credo che TedX significa anche questo,
significhi innovazione.
La mia definizione di innovazione
è una strada che tutti percorrono.
Tutti in fila a seguire
i passi di chi ci precede,
poi c'è qualcuno,
spero che quel qualcuno sia
proprio tra queste fila oggi,
che vede questa strada
e si volta da un'altra parte
dove non c'è il cammino.
E sceglie,
sceglie di fare il primo passo
di quello che diventerà
un nuovo percorso
lì dove non esiste.
Questo è il significato vero
dell'esplorazione,
in questo senso
la mia presenza qui oggi
è giustificata perché lo spazio
è il luogo dell'innovazione.
In tutti i sensi, dalla scienza
alla tecnologia.
Poiché non sapevo se sarei venuto
oggi a parlare a questo pubblico
non ho preparato una serie di slide,
non ho preparato un video,
ho fatto una sola cosa.
Ho scelto una foto
per parlarvi di meraviglia e oscurità.
Probabilmente - ho sentito qualche
"oooh" nel pubblico -
Probabilmente molti...
spero di no,
ma probabilmente alcuni di voi
hanno visto questa foto,
una delle mie foto preferite.
Dovete sapere che io non sono
un fotografo,
non ho molta esperienza,
non sono un tecnico della fotografia.
Mi sono un po' giostrato
questo mio ruolo in orbita
ho imparato ad utilizzare
le macchine fotografiche.
Quindi questa foto
da un punto di vista della tecnica
è una foto scattata a mano.
Non è granché, non è eccezionale.
Non sono un buon fotografo.
Però c'è qualcos'altro in questa foto
che va al di là della tecnica
e che invece tocca altri argomenti.
Io vorrei cominciare dell'oscurità.
Vi chiedo di vedere quello
che non c'è nella foto.
Guardatela bene.
Cosa non c'è in questa foto?
Quello che non c'è sono i confini.
Questa è una foto che guarda l'Europa,
parte dell'Europa, il Mediterraneo,
volando verso est, guardando verso ovest
dalla Stazione Spaziale Internazionale.
Noi sappiamo che lì da qualche parte
c'è la Francia, da qualche parte
c'è la Germania
c'è la Spagna e il Portogallo.
Io sfido chiunque a tracciare
una linea
che distingua questi paesi.
È impossibile.
È impossibile in questa foto
ma non perché siano sbiaditi
o perché i pixel non siano
abbastanza netti
è perché queste linee non esistono.
E vi assicuro che io l'ho visto
con i miei occhi,
è una immagine molto più nitida
di quella che purtroppo vi presentano.
È una immagine talmente nitida
che fa parte della mia memoria
che ormai è diventata la mia storia.
Questi confini sono inesistenti.
Guardate ad ovest dell'Adriatico
quei paesi che nel secondo dopoguerra
si sono sbrindellati,
sono stati frantumati
in tante diverse etnie.
Andate a cercare quei paesi.
Andate a cercare quella divisione.
Non c'è, non esiste.
Questa è l'oscurità.
Sono dei confini
che noi abbiamo inventato,
che noi abbiamo creato
con la nostra storia
con il nostro passato.
Io spero che adesso
ci sia un momento evolutivo.
La storia va in avanti.
È come un vento.
Il nostro Presidente della Repubblica
ha detto delle parole bellissime,
"esiste il vento della storia".
Questo è il momento in cui
il vento della storia soffia fortissimo
e cerca di eliminare questi confini
in un processo unico
che è quello dell'Europa,
dell'Europa unita.
Ed è per questo che io vi parlo
dell'oscurità
e parlo della meraviglia.
Quello che si vede di notte
che supera l'oscurità,
questa luce è l'opera dell'uomo.
Di giorno l'uomo sparisce dalla terra.
Le terre degli uomini sono
restituite alla loro forma naturale,
ancora una volta senza confini,
senza le opere dell'uomo,
senza la sua presenza ingombrante
scomoda, inquinante.
Quindi è bellissimo vedere la terra
così come sarebbe apparsa
milioni di anni fa
senza questa forte presenza.
Di notte, invece, l'uomo
si erge al di sopra di questo
suo essere umano meschino
e si presenta con questa meraviglia.
Perché vi assicuro che vedere l'Europa
tutta illuminata di notte è meraviglioso.
È una costellazione più brillante
di qualsiasi stella
o gruppo di stelle si possa vedere
in cielo
e non c'è soluzione di continuità,
guardate.
È tutta unica.
Con le grandi città collegate dalle
nostre autostrade dalle nostre strade
dai nostri mezzi di comunicazione
come una rete neurale
di un unico grande cervello,
un unico grande organismo.
Questa è innovazione nel senso
più ampio,
l'innovazione di una società.
L'evoluzione dell'umanità
verso un passo futuro
in cui riusciremo a lasciare indietro
le storie meschine di divisione
di sopraffazione.
Lasceremo indietro i nazionalismi
lasceremo indietro l'idealismo.
L'ideale.
Invece, ci soffermeremo sulle idee
quelle si che sono importanti:
saremo tutti insieme
perché tutti insieme saremo più forti.
E questo è il nostro grande desiderio.
Dobbiamo fortemente desiderarlo
di fare questo salto evolutivo.
Le generazioni che ci guardano
nel futuro sono già lì.
Quindi il mio invito
è di guardare questa immagine,
vedere il potenziale dell'uomo
che è quello di superare
i confini interni che ci dividono,
gli unici confini che veramente esistono
e di guardare ancora una volta
con sguardo innovativo al di là
della strada tracciata verso l'orizzonte.
Quell'orizzonte è il futuro dove
noi stiamo andando.
Grazie.
(Applausi)